L'homme a toujours été fasciné
par les forces extrêmes de la nature.
Certains en font même un métier,
comme les chasseurs de tornades.
Aussi passionnant
qu'il puisse paraître,
ce métier comporte des risques.
Les puissances de la nature
peuvent se retourner
à tout moment contre l'homme.
Le métier de volcanologue
est également très exposé.
Il est rempli
de revirements incontrôlables.
Un faux pas
et l'ascension d'un volcan
pourrait être la dernière.
Greg Johnson est l'un des meilleurs
chasseurs de tornades professionnels
en Amérique du Nord.
Avec plus de dix ans
d'expérience, ses collègues et lui,
nommés les Tornado Hunters,
ont sillonné l'Amérique
sur plus de 200 000 kilomètres
à bord de leur camion blindé pour filmer,
photographier, étudier et diffuser
des informations sur les tornades.
Nick Varley est volcanologue
et professeur-chercheur fondateur
du département volcanique
à l'université de Colima au Mexique.
Il a exploré des dizaines
de volcans à travers le monde
pour améliorer la recherche.
Il concentre aujourd'hui
l'essentiel de son exploration
et de sa quête de données
sur le volcan de Colima,
qui fait partie des volcans
les plus dangereux au monde.
Greg Johnson et Nick Varley
sont deux fervents travailleurs,
conscients qu'à tout moment, un faux pas
pourrait avoir raison de leur passion.
Le métier de chasseur de tornades
comporte une grande part de risque.
La moindre faute d'appréciation
peut mener tout droit à la catastrophe.
Les risques d'accident sont très fréquents
dans le métier de chasseur de tornades.
À tout moment, un demi-tour
soudain de cette force de la nature
peut s'avérer fatal.
Chaque année, aux États-Unis,
les tornades font, en moyenne,
soixante-dix victimes
et mille cinq cent blessés.
La saison des tornades est à son summum.
Aujourd'hui, Greg
et ses équipiers se préparent à partir
à la poursuite des tornades,
dans le centre des États-Unis.
Je suis Greg Johnson, photographe,
et mon rôle est plutôt simple.
Je dois faire les photos
les plus incroyables possibles.
Je suis aussi responsable
de la planification,
c'est-à-dire, savoir où nous allons
et comment nous y allons.
Il y a aussi Chris Chittick, le vidéaste,
qui s'occupe de la diffusion en direct
sur internet et de nos vidéos en ligne,
et Ricky Forbes, qui est le conducteur.
Il apprend l'art de la photographie
au fil de nos déplacements.
C'est notre équipe.
Nous sommes trois.
Maintenant, c'est la mi-saison
de la chasse aux tornades.
Ce n'est pas une longue période,
douze semaines tout au plus.
Certaines années,
c'est plutôt neuf ou dix semaines.
On n'a pas encore eu
cette fameuse tornade.
Cette tornade légendaire,
des prairies, à laquelle on pense
quand on regarde
des films ou des émissions à la télé.
On n'en a pas eu en plein jour
cette tornade parfaite, immense,
touchant le sol,
et qui donne de superbes photos.
Il n'y en a pas eu cette année.
On a beaucoup de photos,
mais je ne fais pas ce métier
et je ne parcours pas
des milliers de kilomètres
pour prendre de jolies photos.
Je veux faire des photos de tornades.
Père de quatre enfants,
Greg est bien conscient
des nombreux risques
associés à son activité.
C'est mon métier.
C'est comme ça que je gagne ma vie.
Au début, c'était difficile de partir.
Ça ne me dérange pas
quand je suis sur la route.
Le moment difficile, c'est
de monter dans la voiture et de partir.
Je ne crois pas que les enfants ont peur,
mais je pense que ce qui les affecte,
c'est quand les gens
font des commentaires.
Ils disent : "Votre père est fou."
Ils ne disent pas ça.
Personne ne t'a
jamais dit que j'étais fou ?
D'accord, peut-être que j'ai menti.
Ils ne réalisent pas que
je risque ma vie à chaque fois
que je pars sur la route.
Pour Greg, la sécurité prime avant tout
et sa grande expérience en la matière
lui permet de bien prévoir tout
l'équipement indispensable à l'expédition.
C'est pourquoi, lui et son équipe
se déplacent dans un véhicule blindé,
hautement modifié.
Ils se protègent ainsi de la plupart
des risques de collision avec des débris.
Ce camion, c'est Flash.
On peut compter sur lui.
C'est comme un cocon qui nous protège.
Tout ce qui se passe
dans le camion doit être sécurisé,
qu'il s'agisse de conduire
en direction d'une tornade,
ou de rester assis à l'intérieur
pendant une tempête de grêle.
On doit être en sécurité.
Non, ce n'est pas vrai !
Ils devraient être au sous-sol.
C'est terrible !
Pour qu'on soit en sécurité,
ce camion a été renforcé
afin qu'il puisse résister
à tous les imprévus.
De notre immense
pare-chocs d'acier, au toit,
tout le véhicule est enduit
de Line-X, une matière pare-balles.
Lors d'une tornade, le vent peut
atteindre quatre cent kilomètres heure.
Tous les débris qui s'envolent,
qu'il s'agisse d'une roche,
d'un morceau de bois,
ou d'un pan de maison,
lorsqu'ils sont dans les airs,
ça peut faire beaucoup de dommages.
On a aussi cette cage de sécurité.
Elle est conçue pour être placée
dans la charpente du camion.
Si le véhicule est renversé,
elle protège l'habitacle du camion.
Là où on est assis
et où on passe tout notre temps.
Elle nous empêche d'être écrasés.
Malgré toutes ces précautions,
le camion porte les marques
de ses expéditions antérieures.
Son pare-brise
a été fracassé à huit reprises.
Tout comme Greg,
Chris Chittick, son partenaire,
a choisi d'exercer ce métier.
Il est conscient des risques pris
en tant que chasseur de tornades
et de l'inquiétude
que ressent Chelsea, sa femme,
lorsqu'il part en expédition.
Ma femme n'apprécie pas
beaucoup ce que je fais,
mais elle ne m'empêchera
jamais de faire ce que j'aime.
Elle pleure à chaque fois que je pars.
Le problème ce n'est pas
la chasse aux tornades.
Je crois que c'est
plutôt l'aspect sécurité :
le danger, la conduite, les longues
heures passées sur la route et tout ça.
C'est ce qui lui fait peur.
Quand Chris n'est pas là,
c'est très difficile pour moi.
Je m'inquiète beaucoup pour lui.
Je passe beaucoup de temps
à essayer de savoir où il se trouve
quand il n'est pas là.
J'essaye de suivre les diffusions
en direct pour m'assurer qu'ils vont bien.
Je crois que c'est
un métier très dangereux.
Je ne comprends pas
pourquoi il veut faire ça.
Ce n'est pas ce que
je souhaiterais qu'il fasse.
J'aimerais qu'il y ait un travail régulier
de neuf à cinq, comme les autres maris.
Greg, Chris et Ricky vont
parcourir environ deux mille kilomètres
pour se rendre à leur premier
point de destination au Texas,
mais ce trajet peut changer à tout moment.
Une nouvelle alerte météo et une analyse
poussée des données du radar satellite,
mèneraient Greg à changer de cap
au beau milieu d'une chasse.
Le métier de volcanologue est,
également, une profession très à risque.
Sur le terrain, les dangers
de blessures sérieuses
ou même de mort, sont omniprésents.
À l'aide de divers instruments,
le volcanologue doit observer,
étudier et effectuer des prélèvements.
Cela, sur des volcans
en pleine activité.
Nick Varley,
enseignant d'origine anglaise,
concentre depuis quelques années
ses recherches sur le volcan de Colima,
l'un des plus dangereux au monde.
Ce matin, Nick se prépare
à rejoindre ses étudiants
pour organiser
une expédition sur le volcan.
Avant de partir,
ce père de famille attentionné
passe un petit moment avec son fils.
Tu vois ? C'est à cause du gaz.
Celui la provient d'une
énorme éruption du volcan Colima.
Tu vois,
celui-ci est différent de l'autre.
Maman t'a dit que j'allais au volcan ?
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Ça te fait peur que j'y aille ?
-Non.
Parce que ça stresse
maman parfois, n'est-ce pas ?
Tu sais que je reviens toujours.
-Je sais ça.
Tu préfères celle-ci ?
-Je préfère celle-là.
La journée du volcanologue
commence maintenant.
Nick se dirige vers le lieu
de rencontre pour l'expédition
à l'université de Colima.
Le matériel scientifique est déjà préparé.
Nous devons charger le camion, ce qui
j'espère, ne prendra pas trop de temps.
Ensuite, nous devons aller à l'université.
La température est bonne
pour cette période de l'année.
Elle peut rendre les choses difficiles,
alors il faut profiter aujourd'hui.
Nick a lui-même fondé le
département de volcanologie de Colima
et ses étudiants
viennent des quatre coins du monde.
Aujourd'hui, le volcanologue
et quelques élèves
graviront le volcan
à la recherche d'échantillons
et de données très utiles.
Elles serviront aux analyses
pour les prévisions d'activité volcanique
et pourront ainsi aider à sauver des vies
lors d'évacuations de population
vivant près d'un volcan.
Le volcan est très
intéressant en ce moment.
Il est en éruption depuis 2013
et en constante évolution.
Si les différents éléments sont instables,
il peut devenir plus dangereux
et provoquer une plus grosse éruption.
C'est important en ce moment de collecter
autant de données que nous pouvons.
Il est très difficile
d'étudier les volcans en éruption,
parce que plusieurs d'entre eux
sont trop dangereux pour être approchés.
L'avantage que nous avons ici,
c'est que ce volcan est en éruption,
mais qu'on peut s'en approcher.
C'est une opportunité très rare,
c'est difficile de trouver ça ailleurs.
Pas de temps à perdre.
Nick et son équipe
préparent tout le matériel nécessaire
pour leur expédition sur le Colima.
À cette période de l'année,
nous nous battons
constamment contre les éléments,
parce qu'il peut pleuvoir énormément sur
le Colima pendant la saison des pluies.
Quand un ouragan passe,
il peut pleuvoir sans arrêt
pendant trois ou quatre jours
et ça devient impossible
de faire quoi que ce soit sur le terrain.
On attend toujours
un jour comme aujourd'hui,
qui nous offre une opportunité idéale.
Nick n'en est pas
à sa première ascension du volcan.
Il connaît bien le terrain, mais
devra constamment être sur ses gardes
pour ne pas mettre
en danger ses étudiants.
Allons par là, Ricky.
Quand la nature se déchaîne,
les chasseurs de tornades
vivent des moments intenses,
mais devant ce phénomène
d'une puissance hors norme,
la curiosité reste plus forte que la peur.
Arrête ici ! Arrête ici !
Greg et son équipe ne sont pas près
d'oublier cette journée d'été de 2014
dans la plaine de l'état du Nebraska.
Ils sont tombés sur une super tornade
qui rase tout sur son passage.
Les sirènes d'alerte aux tornades
retentissent en ce moment
dans cette petite ville
de Pilger, au Nebraska.
On a cette tornade géante au sol ici.
C'est exactement
ce qu'on cherchait cette saison.
C'est notre récompense, oui !
C'est vraiment incroyable.
Regarde la taille de ce truc.
Elle se dirige
tout droit vers cette ville.
Regarde à gauche,
Il y en a une deuxième juste là.
Pour observer et relever des informations,
il faut se rapprocher
au plus près des tornades.
Il faut oublier sa peur,
mais rester toujours concentré
sur le danger omniprésent.
Allons-y.
Allez, allez, on y va.
Tout se joue entre risque et
raison devant un pareil spectacle.
Merde.
Quel monstre.
As-tu entendu ça ?
Elles sont derrière ce monticule.
Derrière la colline.
Les tornades évoluent sur
une dizaine de kilomètres en moyenne
et sont larges d'une centaine de mètres.
À l'intérieur, les vents sont
les plus violents de la planète.
Ils peuvent atteindre
jusqu'à cinq cent kilomètres heure
et tout dévaster sur leur passage.
Ce n'est pas bon, ce n'est pas bon.
On pense que les tornades
tournent comme ça, mais c'est faux.
Elles ne tournent pas comme ça,
elles partent en tir-bouchon.
La force verticale
à l'intérieur d'une tornade
est aussi puissante
que la force horizontale.
On risque d'être frappés par des objets
et aussi de s'envoler dans les airs.
Quand on se trouve
à l'extérieur d'une tornade,
le danger, c'est le vent
qui entraine tout vers l'intérieur,
mais on se débrouille avec ça.
Si tu es coincé
dans la circulation d'air,
tu risques de t'envoler dans les airs
et cet aspect est
effrayant et dangereux.
Quand on se trouve près d'une tornade,
on est soumis à un changement extrême
de la pression barométrique.
Une tornade,
c'est un système de basse pression.
Plus on s'approche de la tornade,
plus la pression baisse.
C'est ce phénomène
que les gens qui se sont retrouvés
au cœur d'une tornade ont vécu.
Cette impression
que leurs oreilles vont exploser.
C'est ma passion.
Parfois, j'ouvre une photo
sur mon ordinateur
et je ne peux pas croire
que c'est moi qui l'ai prise.
Je m'assois et je la regarde.
Certaines photographies sortent du lot.
Il y en a que j'ai prise
l'an dernier à Pilger,
une petite ville du Nebraska.
Dans notre cercle de météorologues,
on va parler de cette journée
pour les 50 prochaines années.
On a observé des tornades jumelles
l'une à-côté de l'autre.
Chacune d'entre elles avait
une largeur de près d'un kilomètre
et elles parcouraient le sol
en même temps, côte à côte.
J'ai été témoin de ça juste devant moi.
Deux tornades au sol.
Tu veux rire ?
Mon Dieu.
L'anticipation est primordiale
pour nos chasseurs de tornades,
car il suffit d'un revirement
soudain de trajectoire mal interprétée
et c'est la tragédie.
Allons-y Ricky.
Elles se dirigent par là.
Tout va bien,
je ne te mettrais jamais en danger.
Avant chaque départ,
Nick doit se rendre à l'observatoire
de la protection civile de Jalisco,
au pied du Colima.
Il doit rencontrer l'équipe de techniciens
qui surveille, 24 heures sur 24,
les activités du volcan pour s'assurer de
ne pas se faire prendre dans une éruption.
Après avoir obtenu
les autorisations nécessaires,
le petit groupe se lance
sur la piste cahoteuse
qui va les conduire au pied du volcan.
Rien ne garantit cependant
la sécurité de l'équipe
dans un environnement
qui peut se transformer
en immense piège à tout moment.
Plusieurs dangers
guettent les volcanologues :
explosions, chutes
de roches pyroclastiques,
cendres chaudes,
enlisement de terrain
ou encore coulée de lahar.
À cette période de l'année,
Nick doit faire face un autre danger.
Le principal danger ici,
à cette période de l'année,
c'est la pluie,
parce qu'elle se mêle aux dépôts
qui se trouvent dans le haut du volcan
et les entraîne avec elle et forment
des lahars, des coulées boueuses.
Ces coulées de boue
peuvent devenir très épaisses
et entraîner avec elles
de gros débris potentiellement dangereux.
Les lahars coulent très souvent par ici.
Là, c'est une ancienne coulée de lahar
qu'on peut voir devant nous.
On se retrouve avec une jolie chute
et des coulées de boue.
Après cinq heures de montée,
l'équipe atteint le plateau
où se trouvent les instruments
de mesure et d'analyse.
Les moindres soubresauts
et changements d'humeur de la montagne
sont enregistrés.
Cette matière provient du volcan
et se déplace sur une longue distance.
On peut la recueillir facilement.
En ce moment, c'est trop
dangereux de s'approcher pour collecter
la matière pyroclastique
qui s'écoule du volcan.
C'est tout ce qu'on peut recueillir.
Ensuite, on peut l'analyser
pour voir si la composition du magma
est restée la même
ou si elle est en train de changer.
Panneaux solaires, ordinateur,
enregistreur sismique et caméra thermique,
du matériel à la pointe
de la technologie pour surveiller
le moindre mouvement du volcan.
Cette caméra est orientée vers le volcan.
On enregistre à intervalles réguliers,
selon la programmation,
et on peut sélectionner
les images d'éruption.
La caméra est attachée
à l'antenne parabolique qui est ici.
Nous avons la station radar,
qui se trouve dans une boite étanche.
C'est une pièce
d'équipement plutôt sophistiqué.
Elle émet un signal radar
assez puissant juste au-dessus du volcan.
Ensuite, si l'émission
perçoit un mouvement,
elle le détecte et renvoie un signal.
Après avoir récupéré
les données numériques,
l'expédition se poursuit sur le Colima.
Aujourd'hui, l'activité
volcanique de la montagne
est beaucoup trop dangereuse
pour la gravir jusqu'au sommet.
Malgré les risques,
le volcanologue et ses étudiants
se rendent le plus près
possible du cratère menaçant.
Règle numéro une :
toujours garder une distance
de sécurité avec le cratère,
car lorsqu'un volcan devient dangereux,
la seule véritable
protection reste la fuite.
Après avoir passé
la nuit dans un môtel,
Greg et son équipe
décident de changer d'itinéraire.
Les chasseurs de tornades ne
savent jamais où leur quête les mènera.
On a décidé à la dernière
minute de changer de direction.
On se dirige vers le Colorado maintenant,
qui se trouve à six heures de route d'Ici.
Si on ne part pas maintenant,
on risque de rater le spectacle.
Il n'y a rien de pire
que de conduire pendant six heures
pour rater quelque chose
à cinq ou 10 minutes.
C'est arrivé ?
-Ça arrive, c'est un sentiment terrible.
Nos chasseurs de tornades
décident de quitter le Texas
et de mettre le cap sur le Colorado,
où des conditions propices
aux tornades se dessinent.
Ils vont devoir effectuer un parcours
d'un millier de kilomètres
pour rejoindre le phénomène.
Il n'y a aucune minute à perdre
dans cette course contre-la-montre.
Greg garde toujours un œil
ouvert sur ses instruments de lecture.
Pour être là au bon moment,
un chasseur de tornades
doit avoir acquis plusieurs connaissances
scientifiques au cours de sa carrière.
Ce côté de l'écran nous donne des
informations sur la direction des vents.
Cet autre côté
nous informe de l'intensité de l'orage.
Ce qu'on tente de faire,
c'est de trouver une tempête
qui combine des pluies intenses,
d'importantes chutes de grêle
et des vents rotatifs.
Ce sont ces vents rotatifs
qui finiront par provoquer
une tempête susceptible
de produire une tornade.
La moindre accalmie s'avère trompeuse.
Sur la route des tornades,
le danger survient
quand on s'y attend le moins.
Le fait d'avoir
un orage est plutôt génial.
Ce qui arrive avec ce genre de tempêtes,
c'est qu'elles
produisent des éclairs incroyables.
Tu as vu cet éclair ?
Il était tout près.
Il faut garder ça en tête.
Les éclairs m'effraient
plus que les tornades.
On peut voir la tornade arriver
à plus d'une quinzaine
de kilomètres de distance.
On peut la voir,
on sait où elle sera, mais ça ?
Il y en avait un, là,
et un autre là-bas.
Ce n'est pas une bonne situation
pour nous en ce moment.
On peut l'entendre maintenant.
Écoutez, on peut entendre la grêle
et la pluie tomber sur
le gazon et les buissons là-bas.
On peut l'entendre approcher.
C'est le moment de partir.
Le camion protège ses occupants
des risques de collisions,
mais il protège aussi de la foudre.
Lorsqu'ils sont à découvert,
elle peut s'abattre sur Greg ou ses amis.
Dans le métier, les chasseurs de tornades
doivent souvent changer leurs plans.
Ils sont tributaires
des changements soudains de météo.
La chance est un facteur
important de la chasse aux tempêtes.
La science, les chiffres
et les mathématiques
en sont également des éléments majeurs.
Il y a une raison
qui fait qu'on peut conduire
sur une distance
de trois mille kilomètres en deux jours
et puis arriver quelque
part au moment précis
où une tornade apparait dans le ciel.
On n'arrive pas là par hasard.
Dans huit minutes,
j'espère qu'on pourra voir une
tornade traverser la route devant nous.
Ce qui se produit dans les nuages
maintenant, dépend de la chance.
Je dirais que nous sommes certains à cent
pour cent d'atteindre la tempête.
Mais là où la chance intervient,
c'est que seulement une tempête
sur vingt risque de produire une tornade.
Est-ce que je l'ai eu ?
Où elle est ?
Elle devrait être ici.
Elle devrait être juste là.
Où elle est ?
Dans les deux prochaines minutes,
ces routes deviendront
très glissantes, très dangereuses,
et vous ne voulez pas
rester coincé dans un fossé
lorsqu'une tempête se dirige vers vous.
Dans environ deux à cinq minutes,
il faudra penser à partir.
On peut voir l'air qui est aspiré là-bas.
Tout est aspiré.
On voit du vert, du bleu.
Ça signifie qu'il y a de la grêle
là-dedans en ce moment.
Il commence à pleuvoir ?
-Oui.
Je suis d'accord avec toi.
-Oui, je crois.
Tu crois qu'il faut y aller ?
Greg devra, encore une fois, chercher
une nouvelle formation de tornade.
Depuis le début du XVIII siècle,
les phénomènes volcaniques
ont fait plus de deux cent mille victimes.
Un bon volcanologue
doit toujours faire preuve
d'extrême prudence.
Les volcans sont sournois
et peuvent rapidement
devenir très menaçants.
Quelques accidents fatals
se sont malheureusement produits.
Un couple de volcanologues,
Maurice et Katia Krafft,
a péri le 3 juin 1991
sur les flancs du volcan Unzen au Japon.
Ils étaient reconnus
pour être particulièrement téméraires
lors de leurs expéditions.
Pendant l'ascension du mont Unzen,
les Krafft se sont approchés
trop près d'une zone très risquée.
À l'époque, un professeur
chargé de la surveillance du volcan
leur avait déconseillé la zone,
mais ils n'en ont pas tenu compte
et cette fois-ci,
leur fougue a eu raison d'eux.
Ce n'était pas pour rien
qu'on les surnommait
les "volcano devils."
Jacques-Marie Bardintzeff,
écrivain et volcanologue aguerri,
a visité la plupart des volcans
actifs au cours de sa carrière.
Jacques-Marie connaissait
bien le couple Krafft.
Maurice et Katia Krafft étaient pour moi
un grand frère et une grande sœur.
Il faut savoir que Maurice et Katia
étaient des formidables cinéastes
et photographes.
Ils étaient volcanologues,
mais par le biais de leurs conférences
et de leurs livres, ils vivaient de ça.
Ils apprennent au début
juin 1991, que le mont Unzen
entre en éruption brusquement,
donc ils y vont.
C'était le début de l'éruption
et en début d'éruption, on ne sait
jamais ce que va faire un volcan.
Il était en train
de faire des nuées ardentes
et bien sûr, Maurice et Katia
voulaient faire des images pédagogiques,
scientifiques et d'intérêt général.
C'était le début de l'éruption
et le volcan était en pleine surpression.
La nuée ardente qui est partie,
donc ce nuage brûlant à grande vitesse,
il a été deux fois plus
important et plus large que prévu.
En fait, non seulement
est passé à côté des Krafft.
Malheureusement, il est passé sur eux.
Ils ont été, bien sûr, tués sur le coup,
asphyxiés, brûlés et emportés.
Bien plus bas, sur la route, il y avait
également toute la presse japonaise.
Trente-neuf journalistes
des médias qui étaient là,
à un endroit qui était considéré
comme à-peu-près sûr,
parce qu'il était sur la route,
ont également été tués.
Se protéger des nuées ardentes,
comme dans le cas des Krafft,
ce n'est pas possible,
parce qu'il y a une asphyxie.
Il y a des gaz chauds, brûlants et,
même si on a une protection,
les gaz vont entrer
par en dessous, par les jointures.
Il y a des brûlures, il y a de l'asphyxie.
On pourrait peut-être résister,
trente secondes ou une minute,
mais la nuée ardente
dure plusieurs minutes.
Ça recouvre tout
de gaz brûlant et de cendres.
C'est vrai que la meilleure
défense d'un vulcanologue, c'est la fuite.
Ça a été une énorme émotion
en France, parce que les Krafft étaient
extrêmement populaires.
On les aimait bien,
ils étaient chaleureux et marrants.
Pour moi, ça a été
une leçon douloureuse,
mais je pense que, depuis ce jour-là,
j'ai été encore plus prudent en disant :
"Je ne suis pas à l'abri
d'un mauvais coup,
mais je vais faire encore plus d'attention
en pensant à Maurice et Katia."
L'approche, à la fois scientifique
et éducative, des Krafft
séduisait autant les adeptes
de la volcanologie que le grand public.
Ils ont grandement aidé
à faire évoluer cette mystérieuse science,
mais cela leur a été fatal.
El Reno, Oklahoma.
En 2013, cette région
du centre des États-Unis
allait subir les effets dévastateurs
de la plus large tornade jamais observée
dans ce pays.
Les gars, vous devez voir
ce qui se passe sur le radar.
Nos chasseurs
étaient aux premières loges.
Dans le feu de l'action
et sous l'effet de l'adrénaline,
ils ont mal évalué
le danger qu'ils couraient.
Regardez la rotation
au-dessus de nous, les gars.
[Audio parlé en anglais]
Le service national
de météorologie des États-Unis,
et les chasseurs de tornades
ont repéré une tornade énorme
et extrêmement dangereuse
à neuf kilomètres au sud-est de El Reno.
Las radars indiquent
que la tornade se déplace
à une vitesse de
soixante-quatre kilomètres à l'heure.
Veuillez appliquer les mesures
de sécurité dès maintenant.
Greg, pousse-toi sur la gauche.
Sans le savoir, le piège
est en train de se refermer sur eux.
Viens, allons-y.
Cette journée
aurait pu être leur dernière.
Greg et ses deux partenaires
se sont approchés beaucoup
trop près de la formation.
Allez, viens, allons-y.
La seule fois où on a pris des décisions
qu'ils auraient pu nous mettre en danger,
c'est à El Reno.
L'erreur qu'on a faite,
l'erreur que tout le monde a faite,
c'est d'attendre trop
longtemps avant de partir,
alors que la tornade
se déplaçait droit vers nous.
Elle vient vers nous, les gars,
attendez deux secondes de plus.
Ne bougez pas.
Lorsque la tornade
est arrivée à un certain point
et qu'on était prêt à partir,
lors des 30 secondes qui ont suivi,
parce que ça n'a pas
pris plus que trente secondes,
l'ampleur de la tornade
est passée de quelques mètres de large,
à 2,6 mètres de large
sur environ quatre kilomètres.
Okay, partons maintenant, s'il vous plaît.
En l'espace d'une minute,
on était tous beaucoup trop près.
On a attendu trop
longtemps avant de partir.
Mes oreilles sont bouchées, les gars.
Allez Ricky.
Un gros éclair devant nous.
On est dans le tourbillon en ce moment.
À l'instar de Greg et de son équipe,
d'autres chasseurs de tornades
venus observer le phénomène
se sont trouvés également piégés.
Ce n'est pas vrai, des débris.
Elle approche,
cette chose immense se rapproche.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Au milieu des débris
qui volent dans tous les sens,
ils essaient de sortir de l'enfer.
Tu vas bien, Ricky ?
-Continue.
Pourquoi est-ce que cet homme s'arrête ?
Les chasseurs de tornades
se lancent dans une course folle
dans l'espoir d'échapper au chaos.
Attention à cette voiture.
Des caméras captent
des images saisissantes de ces instants
où tout peut basculer.
Allez, Ricky.
Allez, allez.
J'essaie.
Allez, allez, allez.
Ralentis, ralentis.
Repasse par ce côté.
Beau travail, vraiment beau travail.
On est sorti, on est sorti.
Va plus lentement, maintenant.
-Oui, ralentis.
Leur camion blindé
a été fortement endommagé.
Heureusement pour eux,
ils n'ont pas été blessés
dans cette mésaventure
qui aurait pu les mener
tout droit au drame.
Certains ont eu moins
de chance que les autres.
La série de tornades
qui a traversé l'Oklahoma vendredi
a tué 13 personnes, selon le nouveau bilan
révisé à la hausse par les autorités.
Sept autres personnes, dont cinq enfants,
sont toujours portés disparus.
Parmi les victimes,
trois chasseurs de tempêtes,
dont Tim Samaras,
l'un des plus connus dans le monde.
Tim était un gars
très positif et brillant.
L'un des meilleurs chasseurs
de tempêtes que j'ai rencontré.
Vu l'état dans lequel on a trouvé
le véhicule de Samaras et de Carl Yong,
il était impossible
qu'ils s'en sortent vivants.
Nous chassions la tornade
de El Reno et nous étions tous les deux
sur une route de terre
comme celle-ci, en descendant.
Il était à environ
1,6 kilomètres derrière nous.
Nous étions devant.
La tornade arrivait comme ça
et elle est devenue immense
en trente secondes à peine.
Nous étions prisonniers
des vents extérieurs.
Nous allions à toute vitesse.
La tornade nous retenait un peu,
mais nous nous en sommes sortis.
Tim n'a pas pu sortir parce
qu'il roulait sur une route de terre.
Il ne pouvait pas passer par le champ,
car il conduisait une voiture de location.
Il est resté prisonnier.
Il ne pouvait pas sortir.
La voiture s'est retrouvée
projetée dans la tornade.
Elle a probablement été soulevée
et projetée à nouveau.
C'était très triste.
Cette tornade détient le record
de largeur jamais enregistré à ce jour,
avec une étendue de 4,2 kilomètres.
De force cinq sur l'échelle de Fujita,
ses vents dévastateurs
ont atteint quatre cent
soixante-quinze kilomètres heure.
La tempête de El Reno
était une monstruosité.
Personne ne sait pourquoi c'est arrivé.
En trente secondes, elle est devenue
plus large d'environ trois kilomètres.
Ça n'est jamais arrivé
dans toute l'histoire.
Tim était le gars le plus prudent
que je connaissais en matière
de chasse aux tornades.
Il n'aurait pas essayé.
Sa zone de sureté était probablement
environ un kilomètre et demi d'une tornade
mais ce jour-là,
quelque chose a mal tourné
et il n'a pas survécu.
La force colossale et dévastatrice
de la tornade de El Reno
a malheureusement
porté avec elle la vie de ces passionnés
des phénomènes extrêmes.
Nick et ses étudiants
sont maintenant arrivés
dans l'une des crevasses du volcan.
Nous sommes maintenant
au fond de cette section du ravin,
le ravin de San Antonio.
C'est un peu dangereux ici.
Il faut être prudent,
parce que ces parois sont très instables
et les pierres peuvent tomber facilement.
Nick n'en est pas
à sa première visite sur le Colima,
malgré sa grande expérience,
il sait que chaque ascension
comporte son lot de risques.
Très, très vite, on peut
se retrouver avec des chutes de boue
et de lahars qui coulent par ici.
Ils se forment très rapidement
quand il pleut et peuvent se transformer
en piège mortel.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
il y a peu d'endroits pour s'échapper.
Il y a peu d'issus,
ni d'un côté, ni de l'autre.
Il faut être très prudent.
Le groupe ne peut pas s'attarder
sur ce terrain trop hasardeux.
Chaque minute est comptée.
Il doit se rendre à un point
d'observation au milieu du volcan
pour ériger le campement,
et ce avant la tombée du jour.
Si la lave des volcans
n'est pas un grand danger
pour les volcanologues,
elle peut occasionner de graves séquelles.
Nick le sait bien.
Il en a payé le prix
lors d'une expédition sur un autre volcan.
En plus de celui de Colima, je travaille
sur deux ou trois autres volcans.
L'un d'entre eux s'appelle Isla Socorro.
J'y étais il y a quelques années
pour mesurer le champ magnétique.
Je transportais sur mon dos
un appareil avec une antenne.
À un moment donné,
j'ai marché dans la boue,
qui était un peu chaude.
Je me suis dit : "Je vais plutôt
marcher sur ce terrain plat
où il n'y a pas de boue."
Mauvaise idée.
J'ai fait un pas et, malheureusement,
le sol était recouvert d'une couche
d'environ un centimètre d'épaisseur
qui cachait une boue brûlante en dessous.
Mon pied s'est retrouvé
dans cette couche de boue brûlante,
plutôt épaisse,
mais assez liquide pour recouvrir
et s'infiltrer dans ma botte,
je ne pouvais rien faire.
Malheureusement, j'ai tenté
d'y mettre l'autre pied pour récupérer
celui qui était dans la boue.
J'avais du mal
parce que j'étais dans une pente.
À ce moment-là, je n'ai pas
réalisé la gravité de ce qui se passait.
Cette boule était à 92 degrés
et entrait dans mes deux bottes.
Je me suis assis, j'ai enlevé
mes bottes, puis mes chaussettes.
Au début, je n'avais pas mal, mais
après j'ai ressenti une intense douleur.
Mes pieds étaient gravement brûlés.
Les brûlures que je me suis faite
sur une partie de mon pied
étaient des brûlures au troisième degré.
Pour chaque excursion,
le volcanologue doit optimiser sa présence
et recueillir le maximum de données.
Leur campement installé,
Nick profite de la soirée pour capter
des images infrarouges
à l'aide de sa caméra.
On peut lire une température
d'environ quarante-sept degrés
en ce moment au sommet.
En raison de la distance,
les pixels sont plutôt gros.
Ça veut dire que la température
sera beaucoup plus élevée que ça.
Je peux voir plusieurs points chauds.
Vous pouvez voir
qu'une coulée pyroclastique
est passée par ici,
probablement dans les derniers jours.
Elle a laissé une belle
empreinte chaude jusqu'en bas du volcan.
Pendant toute la nuit,
l'équipe devra se relayer
pour surveiller le moindre
changements du volcan en activité.
À tout moment, elle pourra
ainsi lancer un appel de détresse
et rapidement évacuer le site.
Sur les routes du Kansas, les chasseurs
de tornades poursuivent leur traque.
En ce moment, on se dirige vers
des orages qui se sont formés au Kansas.
On doit pratiquement
traverser l'état en voiture.
Il y a des risques de tornades
aujourd'hui, mais en ce moment
on ne voit rien qui puisse
présager d'une tornade au sol.
Nos aventuriers doivent maintenant
se rendre le plus près possible
de la perturbation atmosphérique.
Lors de grosses tempêtes soudaines,
les routes deviennent particulièrement
dangereuses pour les automobilistes.
Tu as été poussé hors de la route ?
Non. Je suis simplement arrivé trop vite.
Je ne voyais pas
ce qui était sur la route.
Les cours d'eau longeant
les routes débordent rapidement
et rendent la conduite très compliquée.
C'est bon, c'est bon !
Dérapage et embardée, tout peut arriver.
Greg et son équipe
ont souvent à intervenir
pour aider les gens en détresse.
Je te dirai quand ce sera le bon moment.
Dirige-toi vers la droite.
Cet homme conduisait sur cette route et,
regardez ça, l'eau s'écoule de sa voiture.
Il a roulé dans l'eau.
Ce sont des inondations éclair
qui peuvent être aussi dangereuses
que la tornade, sinon plus.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
il conduisait sur cette route
à une vitesse normale
et soudainement, toute cette rivière,
ce ruisseau, a inondé la route.
Il a roulé dans l'eau.
Son véhicule a fait de l'aquaplaning
et il s'est retrouvé dans le fossé.
Heureusement, ce fossé
n'est pas très profond,
mais vous pouvez imaginer
ce qui aurait pu arriver
s'il s'agissait d'un ravin,
ou si la rivière était plus grosse.
Peut-être qu'il serait sous l'eau.
C'est effrayant, mais heureusement,
je crois qu'il va bien s'en tirer.
D'accord les gars,
passez une bonne journée.
Oh non.
Après une longue journée
de chasse aux tornades,
les Tornado Hunter
sont en route vers leur hôtel.
Leur journée n'a pas été des plus
fructueuses, mais, soudain,
la chance leur sourit.
Tout un spectacle de lumière.
C'est génial.
Combien de fois ça nous est arrivé
de nous dire :
"On a fini pour la nuit,
fermons tout ça,"
et puis on voit apparaître
une alerte de tornade dans le noir.
Une nouvelle alerte
météo se déclenche,
les informant
d'une possible formation de tornade,
et ce tout près de leur position.
La rotation est ici, on est là,
on se trouve directement au Nord.
Mais elle bouge.
Traquer une tornade de nuit
peut s'avérer très risqué
et Greg le sait bien.
Il fait noir, on voit
seulement quand il y a un éclair.
On se trouve sous la grêle
et des fortes pluies en ce moment.
Ce n'est pas très sécurisé.
Ricky est inquiet, on ne veut pas se
retrouver au milieu d'une tornade la nuit.
Ce qu'on va faire,
c'est surveiller le radar
et, avec un peu de chance,
dans quelques minutes,
elle va passer juste devant nous.
La pluie va cesser
et on pourra avoir une bonne visibilité.
S'il y a une tornade
au sol avec ces conditions,
on pourrait avoir une chance de la voir.
Greg doit parfois
prendre quelques risques.
Il est toujours à la chasse
aux meilleures images de tornades.
C'est sa passion et son métier.
Laisse-moi voir.
C'est tellement près.
Tornade !
Où ?
-À deux heures au sol.
Un tube entier.
C'est un tube entier
qui s'étend jusqu'au sol.
Magnifique.
J'appelle pour faire état
d'une tornade au sol.
Les chasseurs traquent
sans aucune visibilité.
Ils pourraient à tout moment se retrouver
à l'intérieur même de la tornade.
Il n'y a plus d'électricité.
Non, on n'était pas assez prêt
pour apercevoir des débris,
mais c'était un bel entonnoir
qui s'étendait jusqu'au sol.
Il n'y a plus d'électricité
à Plains non plus.
Il y a de très forts vents
qui nourrissent cette tempête.
L'entonnoir est plutôt étroit.
Au cœur de l'action, Greg
contacte les services d'urgence
pour les aviser en temps réel
des développements du phénomène.
Ça va ?
Je ne pense pas, mon ami.
C'est quoi le problème ?
-Ne bouge pas.
Elle vient de passer.
La tornade est passée près de nous ?
Ça s'est éclairci juste devant nous.
L'électricité est revenue à Plains.
Oh mon Dieu.
On est juste à l'ouest
de Plains en ce moment.
On croit que
la tornade ou des vents très forts…
La tornade bloquait la lumière.
Il n'y a pas eu de panne de courant.
La tornade se trouvait
entre nous et Plains.
Regarde dans cette direction Ricky.
C'est ce que je pense ?
-Non.
Merci beaucoup.
Oh mon Dieu.
Tu vas te faire voir.
C'était trop près.
Elle est là, elle est là.
On y est.
À onze heures et qui remonte.
Vas-y.
-Oui, j'y vais.
Les dangers sont nombreux
et guettent toujours
les chasseurs de tornades.
Sur le terrain,
chaque décision est importante,
car un simple faux pas
et l'expédition pourrait s'avérer
être la dernière.
Le Colima reste imprévisible.
Le volcan est actif
et les signes des mouvements
qui s'exercent en profondeur
sont observables sur les flancs.
Au cours des dernières heures,
une coulée est apparue.
Nous nous trouvons maintenant
à environ deux kilomètres du volcan.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
il y a des chutes de pierres
qui surviennent constamment.
Je dois être très prudent.
Je dois être prêt à courir
au cas où une pierre viendrait à tomber.
C'est important de récolter
un bon échantillon de cette coulée
pour l'analyser
et voir s'il y a eu des changements
dans la composition du magma.
On peut voir la différence
dans ces pierres, juste là.
Regardez celles-ci.
Nick décide de retourner
là où il a disposé
ses instruments
de mesure et d'échantillonnage,
mais il craint le pire.
Son matériel a cessé
de transmettre ses données
au moment même de la dernière coulée.
Ici, on peut voir la station radar juste
après le passage de la nuée ardente.
Comme vous pouvez le constater,
l'instrument était juste ici,
à l'intérieur d'une boîte
de métal, alors ça va.
Voici l'antenne parabolique.
Elle a été tordue et elle s'est brisée.
Elle a été fracassée
par de larges pierres.
Vous pouvez voir
que la peinture a été brûlée,
comme plusieurs
des arbres à l'entour d'ailleurs.
Nick sait qu'il court de grands
risques à chacune de ses expéditions,
mais son but est justement
de trouver les méthodes les plus fiables
de prédiction d'éruptions volcaniques.
Il y consacre toute son énergie.
C'est tout ce que je peux transporter.
Je retourne me mettre en sécurité.
Le Colima, surnommé volcan de feu,
peut exploser à tout moment
et causer d'importants dégâts
aux populations avoisinantes.
Cuidad de Guzmán,
une ville de plus de 97 000 habitants,
est située tout près du volcan.
Il est difficile
de sensibiliser ces habitants
aux dangers potentiels du Colima.
Plusieurs d'entre eux se sont
habitués à la présence de ce volcan,
qui partage leur quotidien.
C'est une réaction plutôt typique.
La première réponse qu'on reçoit,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de crainte.
Les gens n'ont pas vraiment peur
du volcan, mais quand on leur demande :
"Êtes-vous certains
que rien ne peut arriver ?"
Ils répondent :
"Non, je ne sais pas vraiment."
Je crois que de nombreuses personnes
essaient simplement de ne pas y penser
pour continuer à vivre leur vie.
Dans ces villages,
la majorité des gens sont pauvres.
Les catastrophes naturelles
ne sont pas leur préoccupation.
C'est plutôt de vivre en
n'ayant pas assez de l'argent.
En réalité, avoir un peu peur
serait sans doute une bonne chose.
La situation est problématique
quand il y a une importante éruption
et qu'il faut évacuer les gens.
Les gens ne sont pas
très heureux de partir
et doutent des motivations
de ceux qui ordonnent l'évacuation.
La situation idéale,
en ce qui concerne n'importe quel volcan,
serait que la population locale
soit un peu effrayée.
Comme ça, si les autorités disent :
"Nous devons évacuer," ils le font.
Le gouvernement doit
toujours rester en alerte
pour évacuer rapidement
la région en cas de catastrophe.
Nick désire survoler le Colima
pour prendre quelques clichés
et observer les activités
du volcan sous un autre angle.
Il peut être très risqué
de s'aventurer en avion
trop près du cratère en pleine activité.
La chaleur intense
et les projections de débris
pourraient causer bien
du tort à l'appareil et à ses occupants.
Ils doivent être très prudents
et ne pas rester trop longtemps
au-dessus du Colima.
C'était un succès.
Nous avons réussi à voir
un nouveau développement du dôme
parce qu'il s'étend
maintenant vers le nord,
ce que j'ignorais avant le vol.
Nous avons vu un rocher tomber,
ce qui est une bonne façon de prouver
que le dôme s'étend, qu'il est actif
et qu'il a atteint maintenant
le bord du cratère.
On devrait à observer
de plus en plus de chutes de pierres
chaque jour du côté nord.
L'expédition terminée, Nick
peut maintenant rassembler
toutes les informations
recueillies sur le terrain.
Elles lui permettront
de réaliser plus précisément
le modèle thermodynamique du volcan.
Ce modèle permettra d'anticiper
et de mieux prévoir les activités
volcaniques du Colima.
Les métier de chasseur
de tornades et de volcanologue
sont des professions
qui ne peuvent s'exercer sans passion.
Grâce à elles, Greg et Nick
surpassent leurs appréhensions
face aux puissantes forces de la nature.
S'ils acceptent
de prendre autant de risques,
c'est qu'ils savent que leurs informations
seront capitales pour
protéger les populations en danger.